empezamos en nuestra revista de prensa
con el tema del día las elecciones es de
medio término en Estados Unidos y esa
ola republicana que al final no terminó
por consolidarse y para todos los
detalles me acompañan el estudio mi
compañera Marta Moya Marta Un saludo
para usted Buenos días Buenos días
Ángela vamos a comenzar hablando
entonces de lo que dicen los medios
Habla por ejemplo el New York Times Así
es Ángel la vamos a empezar por la
prensa local evidentemente hemos
destacado el New York Times que hace un
Live hace una retransmisión en directo
de todos los resultados Este es un
titular que ha ido fluctuando a lo largo
de la noche pero cuando hemos recogido
este titular decía feterman vence
sobreos en el senado Katie Hot hotchup
gana en Nueva York la demócrata
consolida su poder en el estado de Nueva
York mientras el demócrata John federman
vence sobre meme 2 en el estado de
Pensilvania en esa carrera senatorial
que es una de más o era una de las más
controvertidas y de las más
difíciles de conseguir para los
demócratas en la noche de hoy también
destacamos en esta portada del New York
Times esas dos agujas que van haciendo
un poco las proyecciones de los
resultados tanto en la cámara de
representantes como en el senado y
seguimos con el
Washington post que dice el congreso
pende de un hilo mientras los demócratas
desafían las expectativas los
republicanos apoyados por el ex
presidente Donald Trump parece que se
quedan un poquito lejos de las
expectativas que tenían en esta ola roja
que habían denominado esta sangría
republicana y los republicanos críticos
con el ex presidente han sacado mejores
resultados esa mayoría exigua tanto en
la cámara como en el senado a la espera
de confirmarse los resultados parece que
termina por aliviar a los baratas que
encontrarán los televidentes si
consultan político el político hace un
titular muy claro La ola roja que no fue
cinco conclusiones de una noche
decepción ante para el partido
republicano sostiene este análisis
previo de político que lo que decíamos
con el Washington post los candidatos
favoritos de Donald Trump parece que
quedaron un poco lejos de esas
expectativas y por eso el liderazgo del
expresidente se ve un poco comprometido
sobre todo depende de esa anuncio de la
carrera a 2024 que habría pronosticado
para la semana que viene otra de las
claves es que los demócratas aguantan
con bailen o a pesar de biden que el
extremismo no favorece ni de un lado ni
del otro que los demócratas siguen en
problemas en Estados como Texas O
Florida y que las dificultades de los
republicanos se espera que esperaban
lanzar investigaciones a la
administración vaiden ahora tendrán que
reformularse y vamos a cerrar
rápidamente este primera parte de
análisis con el Wall Street journal el
Western journal titula de momento la
carrera continúa estrecha por el control
del senado los demócratas dan un giro en
el senado con la victoria de Pensilvania
con John federman y los republicanos
ganarían en la cámara según estas
estimaciones en la prensa internacional
también se habla del tema vamos a
empezar con el país el país titula la
resistencia demócrata deja en el aire el
control del congreso en un escrutinio
muy ajustado el partido republicano en
condiciones de ganar la cámara e y el
senado se complica por el fracaso de lo
que hemos venido reportando el fracaso
de la ola roja entre los demócratas una
mezcla de alivio y resignación y aunque
me parece que van a mantener el control
del senado solo con el bloqueo de la
cámara de representantes que parece que
va a caer del lado republicano ya podría
poner en aprietos avaiden viene y
también se pronuncian lemons Lemon en la
misma línea titula La ola roja
que no sucedió la diferencia entre una
victoria y una derrota a veces se reduce
a la perspectiva al contraste entre las
expectativas y los resultados eso dice
evidentemente es un tema de interés a
nivel internacional
que dice este periódico alemán titula
Trump fastidia la noche a los
republicanos por lo que veníamos
comentando no al final esos candidatos
más alineados con el expresidente han
sido los que han red ha hecho retroceder
esas expectativas bueno Eso Eso lo
veremos en los análisis con los
invitados y podremos profundizarlo
además también por el lado del Reino
Unido hay noticias con the Garden Así es
Ángela y cita pues unas palabras de
Donald Trump que dice noche interesante
Trump tiene poco que decir ya que los
republicanos no cumplen Trump organizó
una velada para seguir los resultados en
su Resort en mara lago en Florida y
pareció taciturno y poco tenía que decir
acerca de los resultados Ya que parece
que no se van a consolidar para bien o
para mal de Donald Trump siempre
protagonista El Clarín El Clarín titula
rápidamente pelean bota a voto por el
congreso pero no hubo una buena
republicana y viene el medio usa today
está haciendo además darte un análisis
que venimos siguiendo desde temprano en
la redacción y que es preliminar sobre
estos resultados que es lo que nos dice
este seguimiento Pues si el usa Y tú de
dice los resultados de las elecciones de
mitad de término son más un rizo rojo
que una ola Roja se preguntan sostiene
este análisis del yorkshire today que
entraron en juego cuestiones como el
crimen la inflación el tema del aborto
que al final los jóvenes a la espera de
conocer esa demografía electoral que se
que sabremos en las próximas horas
expresaron en las urnas sus
preocupaciones pese a todo al menos 140
negacionistas republicanos de las
elecciones de 2020 habrían ganado las
elecciones y este número podría aumentar
a la espera de los últimos resultados y
destaca también este análisis del yo soy
today que por ejemplo Brian kemp que
ganó la gobernación de Georgia del
estado de Georgia que es contrario a
Trump se hizo frente con la victoria
Sabemos que esta es una ventana de Cara
a las siguientes presidenciales y ahí
entra un nombre ron de Santi dice en la
Florida sobre este tema hablan varios
medios empecemos con Miami Heart Así es
Y es que la victoria de rondas antes en
Florida es un paso importante sobre todo
mirando ya en prospectiva a 2024 el
Miami Herald titula la victoria del
gobernador de Florida de santis le
asegura el estatus de estrella siguiente
paso cuando postularse para presidente
rondes anti recordemos ganó con más de
17 puntos de ventaja a su contendor
demócrata y esto pues le abre las
puertas hacia la carrera presidencial
que ha anunciado que probablemente se va
a presentar y me llama la atención que
usted destacó también en China morning
post Así es porque es que desde el otro
lado de el océano también destacan la
victoria el republicano y sobre todo lo
contraponen con el expresidente Donald
Trump el
amor en Post titula la reelección de
ronda sandis en Florida pone a 2024 y a
Donald Trump a la vista Por supuesto que
no podíamos quedarnos sin hablar del New
York Times Y sí Y destacando también un
tema bastante controvertido Y es que
ayer mismo Donald Trump en un viaje de
vuelta de Ohio le comentó a los
reporteros que viajaban en su avión
privado que amenazaba con revelar
informaciones poco halagadoras contrades
antes y finalmente el candidato
republicano decide presentarse a la
carrera presidencial alertó sé más sobre
el que nadie quizá más que su esposa y
sobre esto tendremos muchísimo más que
hablar así que la espero mañana para
continuar la conversación mañana más
Ángela gracias gracias a usted Marta